nothing gets on my nerves more than the
assumption that people on the far left
may be misguided or naive but they're
basically decent people if you go
through the evidence Jeremy Corbyn is
not a remotely decent man he allied with
the IRA in the 80s when the IRA was
blowing up civilians men women children
he was not as he now claims very
mentation in my view guests talking to
terrorists because you want to get them
on side you only have to go through his
and John Donald's record which we do do
in The Spectator to see that he wanted
him to win he was a supporter he's
allied with Putin's Russia with a
theocratic Iran and again it's just
there's never any criticism he doesn't
go on their propaganda channels and use
it as a platform for criticizing the way
Putin suppressed the democratic
movements in Russia for instance or the
way around persecutes gays or women or
ethnic minorities in Iran he goes along
them because they're anti Western I
could go on but these are the this is a
fundamental immorality a wickedness if I
may use old-fashioned language in the
far left which korban displays in great
and grotesque detail
I mean the evidence about his
electability is just appalling there is
labor have now comfort in Scotland labor
did win in London and Miss lucid econ
and I was very pleased to see that the
city gone runs as an anti corbin
candidate constantly disassociated
himself from him there are companies
measure where leads of the Opposition
are in their first year in office and
Corbin has the worst poll results of any
of them I mean as a side of me that
thinks that some call introduced the far
left reject run a general election and
be absolutely hammered partly because
I'm a journalist and I like a good story
partly because I I think then they would
take responsibility by hold back on that
for two reasons one the far left never
takes responsibility for anything it
won't be their fault early labor and
peaceful the BBC's fault the media mi5
Mossad you name it anyone but then a
second there are millions of people in
this country who needed labor government
they actually needs a Labour opposition
and it would be nice to get one or the
other back quite soon some stories have
been exaggerated supporter Jeremy Corbyn
get abuse and so on however what is
undeniable is that before Corbin came
became leader the Labour Party was a
relatively civil place there was nothing
like this and since then I think
hundreds of thousands of particular
young left-wing activists and learning a
hard political lesson about what the far
left is really like anything goes
anti-semitism
soldiering the homophobia it's as if
veneer of political correctness is
painted very very thinly on many people
on the Left as soon as they're
challenged all the old sneers and
hatreds about women and coos gets poor
out of them I think if you woman or drew
on the left as long as you toe the line
you're okay but my god you start
thinking for yourself and it all comes
down
voting fair and Smith is the only way to
stop beginning what will be a very very
long and a very very hard journey of
getting the writer out of power and
Britain and the longer they leave off
doing that the harder the task is going
to be and it may soon become an
impossible task we may soon have a
country where it's not so much labour
Vettori as moderate or Evie you Kip
right-wing you know you don't you can't
mess about with clowns like Corbett
because history moves on and will soon
wave bye-bye and leave you behind